so my current research is focused on the
spinnaker project spinnaker is a crude
contraction of spiking neural network
architecture well the goal is to build a
machine incorporating a million ARM
processor cores which we can use for
real-time brain modeling applications
now with a million cause we only get to
about 1% of the scale of the human brain
or as I prefer to think of it 10 whole
mouse brains which gives you some idea
of the scale of the problem that that
we're taking on here the physical
machine occupies or will occupy 10
19-inch racks so these are standard
datacenter cases about 6 to 7 feet tall
a bit over 90 inches wide and about a
metre deep the machine will be built
here in Manchester and be based in
Manchester we this stage we have one of
those racks populated so a hundred
thousand cores which is about one mouse
brains worth in terms of network
complexity of course modeling a real
mouse brain requires lots of biological
detail that's that we won't be going
into and knowledge of the network that
doesn't currently exist but just gives
you a feel of the scale of network that
we can model on the machine the physical
design of spinnaker is really reasonably
conventional and we have the chips each
of which has 18 cores on we mount 48 of
those chips on the circuit board which
is about the size of an a4 sheet of
paper so that gives you the order of a
thousand processors on a circuit board
and then we stack the circuit boards in
card frames so they're plugged into into
standard racks quite close together and
which we can do because we've been very
careful to keep the power consumption
under control so there are no real
hotspots on the board and therefore it's
quite easy to air-cool even when they're
spaced quite closely together so we can
get 24 boards across the width of a 19
inch card frame and we can stack those 5
frames high in a 19-inch rack including
allowing space for cooling and so on and
and that gives you 120 boards each with
a
and 64 processors which is a hundred
thousand over 100,000 processors in the
19-inch rack so with the PCBs look
pretty conventional they're just lots of
little black plastic packages and sold
it together in a slightly unusual
irregular array the thing you'd notice
about the board is it is highly regular
I can show you one if you want it would
love to see one yeah is the one yeah
yeah can we show sigh yeah so this is
one of the spinnaker boards
this one's packaged in its own acrylic
box you can see the spinnaker chips the
the name gives us an obvious logo of a
spinnaker sail which is quite attractive
and easy to put on the chip so you can
see there are 48 chips on this board it
may look like they're arranged in a
square but actually topologically
they're in a hexagon so the board is a
hexagonal sub surface of the toroid the
the boards have high speed connectors on
the edges and that allows us to connect
multiple boards together to build the
larger systems so when we put a hundred
thousand cause in a rack all the boards
in that rocker arranged on a single
continuous toroid which keeps the
communication efficient so so this is a
nineteen inch card frame with
twenty-four spinnaker boards in twenty
thousand ARM processors and you can see
the boards are all linked together
through high speed links which puts the
chips into a continuous single toroidal
surface and then the boards are
connected through a network switch to an
Ethernet system which is used for
loading software onto the machine on the
top of the box there's a robot with a
single spinnaker card on its back the
robot is built by your con rat at the
Technical University of Munich and it
has a couple of vision sensors from Toby
Dell Brook at the University of Zurich
on the front and that can be used to
build simple neural robot controllers
that run on the spinnaker board that's a
single-car that's basically controlling
the robot twice eight hundred and sixty
four processors which is more than
a robot will usually get are we going
now I'll show you the big machine that's
sir yes so we're walking through the IT
building here and
so this is a hundred-thousand processor
spinnaker machine it has five of the
card frames that we saw in the previous
shot and now you can see the wiring that
wires them together that's got a lot
more complicated and stringy the primary
problems is it all the wiring yes it's
quite complicated to wire it took a PhD
student four hours to wire the Machine
up in the front the machine is basically
connected to the Ethernet so you can
control it remotely you need some kind
of host machine to compile the network
on and you download it over the net onto
the spinnaker machine itself and then
the thing then runs and the network
evolves in real time even the small card
frames a bit noisy we were very careful
about the power consumption that it was
still packing it together sufficiently
densely that it needs a bit of a draft
to keep it cool
apart from the communications network
the spinnaker architecture looks
reasonably conventional is it's a
massively parallel computer each node is
an ARM processor with a certain amount
of code memory and a certain amount of
data memory and so programming the
processor caused themselves is
reasonably conventional because we're
aiming for real time we use what's
called an event-driven programming model
so instead of having a single program
that runs and loops around the
programmer writes a number of event
handlers which a little bit of little
bits of code that get invoked when
particular events happen such as an
incoming packet arrives from another
neuron that in that calls a little bit
of code which says well what do I do
when this input spikes and what I do is
I look up the synapse is that are
connected to that import and I pass the
relevant level of signal through to the
neurons that are modeled here and that
may or may not cause some of those
neurons to spike and if they do then I
drop more packets into the fabric and so
on the design objective of spinnaker was
to model about a thousand neurons in
real time on each arm core so with a
million core machine we get to a billion
neurons in total now
at the moment we're still tweaking the
efficiency of the software and the
current software implementation maps
about 256 neurons to each core so so we
aren't at the efficiency we're
ultimately aiming for but we're close
the basis of human memory is not really
well understood
I mean computer memory is relatively
very simple we arrange a silicon
structure and we have a cell where we
can store a naught or a 1 and we know
exactly where that information is and if
the cell breaks we lose that information
human memory doesn't seem to be like
that human memory seems to be much more
distributed we all through adult life
losing about a neuron a second and so if
he any in your wrong was critical to a
memory then each neuron we lost will be
some memory going and that doesn't seem
to be the case it seems to be that
biology has found ways to store
information in distributed ways so if
you lose small components you don't lose
the memory the aim of building the
spinnaker machine was to contribute to
the scientific ground challenge of
understanding how the brain works we
have we each have this thing inside our
heads that is clearly vital to the way
we perform our daily tasks but we don't
know how it works fundamentally as an
information processor we don't have deep
knowledge we know lots about the fine
detail about about the neurons and the
cellular biology and we know quite a lot
about how activity moves around inside
the head but the interesting stuff about
for me as a computer scientist is how
information is processed and that's the
levels that we can't access either from
the bottom up or from the top down so
really the only instruments we have for
increasing our understanding are
computer models
now of course the computer models have
to be informed by what we do know about
neuroscience so so this work is very
much a collaboration between disciplines
and neuroscience computer science
psychology all come into play with quite
a lot of
- it's a little bit similar to the
yellow one so we put it'll be closer to
the yellow one and then comes another
data item and no this is obviously quite
similar to the yellow one to be put it
closer to here don't want to just -
something off but I read it off make
sure that my sentences are well
constructed and spelled correctly and so
on so it took a long time and it turned
out that I was spending you know I would
start out with an idea of what I could
do that day and then four hours later